the law prior like I said was you could
try to argue that you didn't know your
dog was capable of inflicting such
damage and then you could sort of get
out of it it was like a one bite free
rule base I got it but probably but by
what this one's acknowledging that if
you're going to get a pit bull you yes
acknowledge it's inherently dangerous
and if anything are gonna happen then
you're on the hook no matter
what you've got one free pass right
that's basically all it was was saying
that when you go to court if you're
attacked by a pit bull you can't sit up
there and say that you had no idea that
this prison dog was right
those incapable of causing damage
basically one pit bull took you down but
you and your family took the rest of
these then that's what
happened pretty much yeah hell yeah yeah
I'm dude that's the other thing I guess
Baltimore as it gets right there
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today